- This episode of Legal Eagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
The infamous K-1 Visa is in the spotlight,
thanks to the mega popular
show, the "90 Day Fiance"
and it's apparently never-ending
number of spin-offs,
like the "90 Day Fiance: The Other Way"
"Happily Ever After", "Before the 90 Days"
"90 Days of Facebook Chats",
"Say Yes! To the 90 Days"
"We Found Love Thanks
To Google Translate",
and the "4 Hour Work Fiance".
Leave it to TLC to turn a
complicated immigration process
into a hit reality show.
The premise of the "90 Day Fiance"
is that an American citizen falls in love
with someone from another country.
Once the couple is engaged,
the U.S. immigration law allows the fiance
to enter the country legally.
The process for this is known
as the non-immigrant visa,
also referred to by its
formal name, the K-1 Visa.
Obviously, Americans can't get enough
of international relationships.
In this video though,
we're going to be talking about love,
marriage, and international travel,
and the legality of the
"90-Day Fiance's" K-1 Visa.
(trumpet sounds)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because even crappy reality T.V shows
implicate complex legal issues.
The fiance non-immigrant visa,
is the document an American citizen needs
to bring his or her foreign
fiance to the United States.
The K-1 Visa permits the
foreign citizen fiance
to travel to United States
and marry his or her U.S. citizen sponsor
within 90 days of arrival.
Once married, the foreign
citizen will then apply
for adjustment of status to
lawful permanent resident
and can stay in the United
States as long as they like.
Who can get the K-1 Visa?
Well, the first requirement
is that the U.S. citizen
and fiance must be
legally allowed to marry
at the time of the petition
for the K-1 Visa was filed.
Marriage laws differ of course,
from country to country
and state to state.
So to get a K-1 Visa,
the marriage has to be legally possible
according to the laws of the United States
and the state in which the
marriage will take place.
Now the second requirement
is that the couple
must have actually met in person.
"90-Day Finance" fans often ask
whether the government cares at all
about how much time these
people spend with each other
before applying for K-1 and
coming to the United States.
The answer is that generally,
the foreign citizen fiance
and the U.S. citizen sponsor
must have actually met in person
at least once within the past two years.
It's probably not too much to
ask when you think about it.
Although the U.S. government
can grant an exception
to this requirement for extreme hardship,
it is extremely rare for this
requirement to be waived.
We have seen lots of examples of people
not knowing each other for very long
before applying for the
fiance visa on the show.
Robert from the most season
of the, "90-Day Fiance"
probably takes the cake.
He met his Dominican
fiance Anny on Facebook
and then scheduled a cruise
to meet her in person.
- And she's hot.
- Robert then left the cruise for a trip
and spent a whopping eight hours with her
before deciding that
this Cardi-B look alike
was his dream woman.
- For people who think this is crazy,
I say, "what the hell,
mind your business."
- I guess it was love at first ship.
Their meeting took slightly less time
than it takes to register a
new car at DMV, but guess what?
Robert and Anny's quick trip
met the bare minimum
requirement for the K-1 Visa.
And there have been several couples
who use mobile phone apps to
communicate with each other
because neither speaks the
other person's language.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Interpreter] I want
to talk about our future.
- But I think we can all agree that "Love"
is the universal language.
So how does one apply for a K-1 Visa?
Well, the application process is long
and it can be very arduous.
You need a lot of paperwork
to get the ball rolling,
including an online
non-immigrant visa application,
plus additional forms if
the person has children,
a passport, a birth certificate,
divorce certificates if applicable,
police certificates from
everywhere the fiance has lived
since the age of 16,
medical examination, photographs,
evidence of the relationship,
and payment of fees.
And that there's just one more thing,
evidence of financial support.
This is actually pretty big deal.
U.S. politicians frequently make claims
about the immigration process
and that they worry
that the people who come
to United States, will be a
financial burden on the country.
But to some extent
immigration laws already have
strict requirements about
financial responsibility
when you come to United States.
During their visa interview
applicants must produce evidence
to the councilor office,
that they will not become a public charge
in the United States.
Public charge refers to
being unable to provide
basic necessities of living like housing,
food, shelter, and clothing.
If a person will become a public charge
the visa will be denied
and that person cannot enter the country.
Now the evidence of financial
support could be information
showing the person can't
financially support themselves
for instance, if the
person has a job lined up
or has a lucrative career as a model,
or they just happened
to be incredibly rich.
Since this is likely not
the case for most people,
they must be able to show
that the U.S. citizen
can provide financial support.
The American citizen will
have to file an affidavit
stating that he or she
will be able to support their new spouse
and any children who come
over with that new fiance.
This is a legally binding contract.
If the person, the citizen is sponsoring
becomes a public charge
and the government has to public services,
the agency providing the help
can sue the American
citizen to recover the cost.
So how does the U.S government decide
whether someone will
become a public charge?
There are many factors, a person's age,
education, work
experience, skills, assets,
financial resources and health,
they're are all taken into account.
And we've seen how the allegation
of a public charge possibility
has impacted the somewhat happy couples.
When Nicole, a single mother,
who struggles to make ends meet
fell in love with man from Morocco,
she knew she would be unable to meet
the financial requirements
for the K-1 Visa,
but her father decided to co-sponsor Azan
and the government gave him a visa.
- I think he sounded sincere,
he sounded like he
wants to be with Nicole.
- He's a good guy and
you guys will see that
when you get to meet him.
- Paul has appeared on two
seasons of "90-day Fiance."
Paul is a Kentucky man in his late 30s
who fell in love with
Brazilian woman name Karine.
- Are you excited to meet me,
you excited that I'm coming to Brazil?
- I don't understand.
- Oh no, she's doesn't understand,
that's not good.
- Despite their age difference,
12 years and language problems,
neither speak the other person's language,
they fell in love.
Paul and Karine first appeared
on "Before the 90 days"
which chronical Paul's
efforts to bring Karine
to the United States.
Paul inquired about
bringing Karine to America
on a K-1 Visa, but he ran into trouble
because he's a grown ass
man living with his parents
who doesn't really work.
- I'm definitely a mama's boy,
I will say that.
I love you.
- I know, love you too Paul.
- Financial affidavit
requires proof of income,
three years of tax
returns, bank statements,
employee verification,
and lots of other stuff
that Paul didn't have.
And Paul's mom wasn't
about to sign the papers
necessary to support Karine.
- I think it's all crazy myself, really.
- When Karine got pregnant,
the couple then appeared
on "90-Day the other way"
where Paul decided to go live
in Karine's very remote
Brazilian home town.
The hapless Pauls exploits in Brazil
included worrying about
whether deadly fish
will be able to swim up his urethra,
and carrying a mosquito
net with him everywhere.
- Better to have it and not need it
than need it then not have it.
- The relationship might not have worked
but it made for some fantastic television.
- Chickens (Paul clucking).
- (laughs)
- Now one of the highlights
of his story line
was Paul running into the jungle
after the government of Brazil
denied him the right to live permanently
in the country of Brazil.
The reason, Paul has a
felony conviction for arson.
- The second case, my ex-girlfriend and I
both took out restraining
orders against each other.
- Just a quality human being,
and as you can see other
countries also have
immigration standards.
But love conquers all.
So that left the couple
back where they started,
trying to assure the U.S. government
that Paul can financially
support his family
if they come to United States.
Now that Paul's mom has grandchildren,
she maybe more willing to
sign that financial affidavit.
I'm told you should definitely stay tuned.
Now "90-Day" fans are always
on the look out for people
abusing the finance application process.
Is this true love or just a foreigner
looking for a green card?
Is the American citizen
sketchy in dangling the visa
as leverage to control
their foreign finance?
Well, Congress has long been concerned
about the possibility of abuse
and fraud, and exploitation
from both the U.S. citizen
and the foreign fiance.
In 2005, Congress enacted
the International Marriage
Broker Regulation Act
to reduce the abuse of
marriage based visa recipients.
The law adds a few safeguards
to the screening process
that are intended to protect
both the visa applicant
and the U.S. petitioner.
For example, if the American petitioner
used a foreign marriage broker,
which are the companies that
are often referred to as,
"Mail-Order Bride" Companies,
they have to disclose it
to the U.S. government
and the broker must meet
certain strict requirements,
not as strict as building
new housing in San Francisco
but still kind of onerous.
All U.S. petitioners must
undergo a background check
and the results must be shared
with the immigrant fiance.
This helps protect a foreign fiance
from arriving in the United States
to discover that the American
fiance is a criminal.
- And I say, "I can't
come you crazy old man
"I don't have green card,"
and he say, "Screw green
cards, they're for poor people
"just get over here."
- U.S. law also mandates
that if a petitioner
has committed specific
violent or sex crimes,
they cannot petition for K-1 Visa.
These are crimes like
homicide, stalking, assault,
domestic violence, kidnapping
and human trafficking.
And what about if the foreign
fiance has a criminal record?
Well, if the fiance has a criminal record,
in most cases, the person will
be ineligible for the visa
or to enter the United States at all.
This is even true when the person's crimes
have been expunged.
Even misdemeanor convictions
can make a person in eligible,
these crimes are listed in Section 212
of the Immigration & Nationality Act.
They include crimes of moral turpitude,
a violation of any drug
law, U.S or foreign,
any kind of drug trafficking,
even if it doesn't result in a conviction,
prostitution or participating
in prostitution in any way,
participating in human trafficking,
whether directly or indirectly
and money laundering.
Now, there are some
exceptions to the rules,
a person may apply for a
waiver of a drug offense
if it was a single offense
of simple possession of marijuana,
and if the conviction
was over 15 years old
before applying for the visa.
But the U.S. has to be satisfied
that the person was rehabilitated,
the person seeking the
waiver also has to show
that admission to the U.S.
would not be contrary
to the national welfare,
safety or security of the United States.
If your overseas fiance was
convicted of only one crime
and the maximum penalty
possible for that crime
is less than one year,
he or she might not need the
waiver of inadmissibility.
This exception does not take into account
the actual sentence
length given to the person
but rather the maximum penalty
that could have been given
as a result of the crime.
The sentencing exception does not apply
however to drug crimes.
Now the "90 day fiance" has
several different couples
impacted by one person's criminal history.
Let's take a look at the
situation for Tiffany and Ronald
from "90 day the other way".
Tiffany is an American
who went to South Africa
and fell in love with Ronald,
Ronald turned out to have a pretty serious
history of gambling.
- I was at my rock bottom,
I had a full blown addiction of gambling.
- He has been charged with armed robbery,
theft and possession of
drugs during a traffic stop.
And Ronald's addiction was so bad
that he wound up selling off his mother's
kitchen appliances, got arrested
and the adjudication was delayed
so he could attend rehab.
Tiffany, who wasn't even fully aware
of the full extent of Ronald's issues,
moved with her son Daniel to South Africa.
Once she learned the truth,
she decided to marry Ronald anyway,
and the two tied the knot just days
after he moved out of rehab.
When Tiffany got pregnant,
she decided she couldn't
stand living in South Africa,
so she returned to the U.S.
Now where does this leave Ronald
her drug and gambling addicted husband?
- His record's a little funky.
There's quite a bit on there.
- Well, at the most recent tele,
Tiffany announced that she
is starting the process
to bring Ronald to the
U.S. on a spousal visa.
When she discussed this with a
lawyer on an earlier episode,
the lawyer explained that
Ronald's arrest history
would be problematic for him
to come to the United States,
even without an actual conviction.
- If there's anywhere in his
record that he admitted it,
that is an admission
for which he can be
determined inadmissible.
- Tiffany however, feels confident
that this history won't matter.
Because she erroneously believes
that "Love" is stronger than lawyers.
But in this particular instance
Tiffany might be right,
violations of gambling laws
are not generally considered
crimes of moral turpitude,
Ronald's other charges could
present problems however,
especially the drug charge,
the USCIS will have to
review the full extent
of his South African arrest,
before they decide if he
can come to United States.
Now, the show also includes
couples who are already married,
people who married a foreign spouse
can apply for a CR-1 VISA
to allow them to immigrate to America.
People who apply for the CR-1
must satisfy most of the same
requirements as the K-1 Visa
including a clean criminal record,
and proving that they
have financial support.
Now traditionally, it was easy to bring
a foreign born spouse to America.
However, that has changed in recent years
largely due to the Trump
administration's travel ban.
The travel ban restricts
immigration from countries
deemed dangerous including Iran, Libya,
Somalia, Syria, Yemen,
North Korea and Venezuela.
We've already seen how
this plays out in the show,
a 19 year old Avery was a
self described party girl
from Columbus, Ohio, until
she met Omar a Syrian online.
The two fell in love and
she converted to Islam,
and Avery married Omar
on a trip to Lebanon.
This means she didn't need to
apply for a K-1 Fiance Visa.
And although Avery's mother
kind of sorta supports
the relationship,
- Oh my gosh.
- She's highly uncomfortable
with the idea of her daughter
moving to Syria to live with Omar,
even though he insists
that this part of Syria
is pretty safe.
- The whole country is in the
middle of civil war Avery.
- I personally think
you're worrying too much.
- Eventually the couple
decided that the best thing
would be for Omar to come to the U.S.
So they applied for the CR-1 Visa,
which is for an immigrant spouse.
Unfortunately for the
couple, the travel ban
restricts the number of
Syrians who can enter the U.S.
even if they are married
to an American citizen.
- The lawyer has worked on,
he said many travel ban cases
and none of them have been approved.
- A CR-1 Visa is supposed
to be easy to obtain
but the Supreme Court
okayed the travel ban
in part because the Trump administration
said it would grant waivers
if a couple experienced undue hardship,
and the foreign spouse was
basically not a terrorist.
In practice, though the waiver
has been harder to obtain,
the Trump administration has been vague
about what constitutes an undue hardship.
According to the Trump administration,
fewer than 5% of people
who apply for waivers
have been approved,
and of this 5% who were approved
the government is in no
rush to provide the visas,
over one third of those
who have been approved
are still awaiting the visa.
That's why some are finding their spouse
an administrative Limbo,
instead of being denied,
the case is placed in
administrative processing
where it may sit for many years.
And although Avery and Omar have indicated
that Omar's application was accepted,
that just means the government
is reviewing the petition
to enter the country.
As a lawyer explained to Avery,
Omar is going to need that waiver
if he has any hope of getting
into the United states.
Now admittedly, lots of "90
day" fans are claiming that TLC
told that lawyer to lie about Omar's hopes
of getting into United States,
but the lawyer's probably right here.
As the form shows Omar's petition
has been accepted for processing,
but it says right on
the bottom of the form
that it is not a visa,
it will still be an uphill
battle for him to be admitted.
Now there are limitations on the K-1 Visa.
A person who enters the U.S.
has 90 days to marry a U.S. citizen
but only that particular U.S. citizen.
If a guy like Syngin from
the new season of "90 days"
decides that Tania is
not really his cup of tea
and he'd rather marry another American,
he will have to leave the country
and start the whole
process all over again.
And it looks like American citizen Rebecca
from "Before the 90 days
is on her second K-1 Visa.
Rebecca was in the middle of a divorce
from her Moroccan born husband
when she met Zeid, a 26
year old from Tunisia.
- Oh my god, I love you
so much, I love you more.
- He's amazing.
- Rebecca who is a private investigator
has now applied for the K-1 Visa for Zeid,
and she better make this one count
since a U.S. citizen is
limited to two K-1 Visas
during their entire lifetime.
This limitation protects foreign
fiance's from exploitation,
because if a U.S. citizen
could apply for K-1 Visas
whenever they felt like it,
they could lure people into the country
with false promises of marriage
and then subject that person
to involuntary servitude or worse.
And although Rebecca's Moroccan ex
hasn't appeared on the show,
his legal status could be up in the air
because of their divorce.
The Immigration Fraud Amendments of 1986
make the foreign spouses
permanent residency conditional
for two years.
This means that the
couples must remain married
for two years for the visa to stick.
If a couple splits up, then the government
may revoke the immigrant spouses
permanent residency status.
This means that the
person is in the country
unlawfully and has to leave.
Of course, there are lots
of procedural hurdles
that can trip up a visa application.
On the brand new season of "90 day fiance"
we met Michael and Juliana,
Michael is a 42 year
"wine entrepreneur" hmm...
And Juliana is a 23 year
old Brazilian model.
When they met at a yacht party in Croatia
when Juliana was about 19 years old,
it was love at first sight, again.
- I don't necessarily believe
in love at first sight,
but it's like we were kindred spirits.
- Although Michael flew
around the world with Juliana,
she was repeatedly denied
a U.S. visitor visa.
The reason, her age and history
were red flags for prostitution.
The U.S. government can
deny entry to any person
who it suspects, is coming
to the United States
solely, principally or incidentally
to engage in prostitution,
or has engaged in
prostitution within 10 years
the date of the application for a visa,
admission or adjustment of status.
Juliana and Michael vehemently denied
that Juliana was ever an
escort or a yatch girl.
Michael stresses that Juliana
was just a beautiful girl
from a very poor village in Brazil
who found love, in a
not so hopeless place,
a yacht full of rich people.
- Certainly a lot of people
that may pass judgment,
may think I'm just an old sleazy rich guy
going after a young hot woman.
It doesn't bother me at all.
- But not surprisingly,
these are the very things
that the government considers red flags.
You don't need to be
convicted of prostitution
to be denied entry.
In practice, the government
is looking carefully
at people who are working in the tourism
or entertainment industries.
Sometimes there's a very fine
line between being a model
and being a model who is also paid
to entertain clients on a boat.
For example,
- Um, let's talk about you,
what do you do for a living?
- Model
- a model, what kind of model
- A fashion model.
- The government is
also actively screening
for victims of human trafficking.
Although Juliana and Michael
protest the questions over their motives,
teen girls from Brazil and Thailand
are often lured into dangerous situations
by men promising lucrative
modeling opportunities.
And unfortunately, escort jobs
can sometimes be the gateway
or the price of admission
to working in entertainment and tourism.
Of course, Michael claims
that he has already invested
more than $150,000 in his
relationship with Juliana,
there didn't seem to be much due process
Michael wind in the second episode,
which focused on Juliana's interview
with the U.S. immigration authorities.
Michael and Juliana have a lawyer
so I'm willing to bet
that they were well aware
that this question would
continue to pop up.
But don't take my word for it,
just Look at this form
the I-485 application
for the K-1 Visa.
As you can see question 35, 36, 37 and 38,
all concerned allegations of prostitution.
And despite the probing questions
eventually the government
decided that Juliana
had not in fact been involved
in illicit activities.
Now many "90 day" fans have questions
about another potential
legal hurdle to the K-1 Visa,
immigrants from countries
where polygamy is legal.
So let's see how this plays out
thanks to the ever popular
couple Michael and Angela.
Angela was a divorced grandmother of six
when she met Michael a Trump loving
30-year-old Nigerian man online.
(paper rustles)
- Oh, sorry.
Angela's first visit to Nigeria
was featured on before the "90 days"
she was going to propose to Michael
but then she discovered
that he committed some,
let's say unusual sexual
indiscretions at a nightclub,
but the relationship was off,
or was it, the two spent the
rest of the season fighting,
Angela accused Michael of
taking from her bank account
without authorization and
broke off the engagement,
later Angela figured out
it was a banking error
and Michael was back in.
But on the next season Angela and Michael
renewed their engagement,
they have applied for a K-1 Visa
but there may be trouble ahead.
The 58 year old grandmother has
promised Michael and his mom
that she will have his
baby as soon as possible.
A fertility doctor said Angela
is down to her very last egg,
so Angela hit up her
daughter for a fresh one.
Angela's daughter has repeatedly refused
to give her mother an egg,
so Michael has proposed having
a baby with another woman.
And in certain areas of Nigeria,
polygamy is in fact legal.
Which brings us to the question,
what happens if polygamy is
legal in a foreign country?
Could Michael bring
another Nigerian spouse
into the country on a K-1 Visa
and then live happily
ever after with Angela
and the other wife?
Well, the answer is no.
Although TLC would dearly love
to have a reality show called
"My Big Fat polygamous fiances"
polygamy is illegal in the United States
and a person cannot immigrate
or become a naturalized U.S. citizen,
if they practice polygamy.
Angela and Michael will
need to resort to plan B,
if anyone has a free egg,
remember, she can tote it,
she just needs the egg.
- I can tote it, I just need your egg.
- Of course the most important
requirement for a K-1 Visa,
is something you won't
find in the U.S. code.
What all of these "90 day
fiances" have in common
is that they are all Instagram experts.
It's pretty much a requirement
for entry to the U.S. these days.
Now if you want to be in "90 day fiance"
or at least raise your Instagram game,
I'd highly recommend Brandon
Woeful Skillshare class
Instagram-Worthy Photography,
Shoot, Edit and Share.
You can go behind the
scenes as Brandon shares
his full process for capturing
whatever kind of portraits
and action shots,
every step is packed with helpful tips,
and unexpected hacks developed
over Brandon's journey
from teaching himself
photography in his bedroom
to inspiring over 3 million
followers on Instagram.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has thousands of
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, music, design,
technology and business.
It's great for Brazilian fiances
who just wants to come to
the U.S. and party on boats.
A yearly membership is
less than $10 per month
but Legal Eagles will get
two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below
plus, it really helps out the channel,
so just click on the link below.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must know topics,
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things,
all free for two months.
So make 2020 the year that
you explore new skills,
deepen existing passions, and
get lost in your creativity
with Skillshare's online classes.
Do you agree, leave your
objections in the comments
and check out my other
real reviews over here
where I talk about
whistleblowers, hearsay objections
and the impeachment inquiry.
Tons and tons of other
legal breaking news.
And as always, I'll see you in court.